[Música]
les doy la bienvenida a un nuevo
episodio de boleto de vuelta que en esta
ocasión nos lleva a sidi buzid una
ciudad tunecina poco conocida pero para
sus habitantes es la cuna de la
revolución que dio inicio a la primavera
árabe hace 10 años la muerte de mohamed
buazizi un vendedor ambulante que se
prendió fuego tras un altercado con la
policía el 17 de diciembre de 2010 fue
el detonante para que surgiera una ola
de manifestaciones no sólo en túnez sino
en toda la región los que resultaron
heridos en la revolución siguen
denunciando la falta de justicia y de
reconocimiento por parte del estado
otros como los miembros del partido del
ex dictador ben alí viven en la
nostalgia y apoyan a los nuevos
participantes en la escena política
actual que niegan el proceso
revolucionario frente a esta vi
polarización política los tunecinos se
comprometen a preservar uno de los
principales logros la libertad de
expresión en un estado de derecho aún en
construcción
diez años después la herida sigue
abierta en esta calle de reggae cerca de
sidi buzid chardy abidi recibió un
disparo en la pierna el 9 de enero de
2011 llevaba días protestando con otros
residentes por la dignidad y la libertad
y ahí es donde me vieron no fuimos
agredidos por agentes de policía que
estaban apostados en la intersección a
pocos metros de nosotros allí también
cayeron mártires tras el levantamiento
de la actividad de sidi buzid
nosotros en regueb salimos el 19 de
diciembre éramos jóvenes no
pertenecíamos a ninguna asociación en el
partido ni organización salimos por el
desempleo y por la obra es decir la
emigración de las regiones marginadas
a su lado atef clics y quien fue herido
en el pecho nos sorprendieron los gases
lacrimógenos y las boletos y a un agente
encapuchado y con un uniforme negro
traté de esconderme detrás de un poste
y mi amigo nizar línea que dios lo
bendiga todavía estaba tratando de dar
media vuelta para wii
la sala le dispararon en esa
intersección de las dos calles
directamente en el pecho la bala le
atravesó y también me impactó a mí
diez años después para estos dos amigos
las esperanzas de la revolución se han
desvanecido cuando salimos a protestar
contra el régimen no pensábamos que
estábamos haciendo una revolución pero
cuando el régimen cayó teníamos sueños
sueños legítimos nos sacrificamos
vivimos sangre por este país pero
vinieron otras personas de la izquierda
y de la derecha y aprovecharon lo que
estaba pasando para tomar el poder para
chad y lo más importante es no caer en
el olvido a través de estos retratos de
los mártires por ejemplo dibujados por
los habitantes de la ciudad número 9
prometieron estos dibujos para la
historia y cada vez que empiezan a
desvanecerse los volvemos a pintar el
estado con la vida y nosotros volvemos a
dibujar
pero la revolución les dejó un sabor
amargo a esos heridos que aún no han
sido reconocidos como tal por el estado
desde hace diez años no se publica
ninguna lista oficial 338 personas
murieron y dos mil 147 resultaron
heridas según un primer recuento pero a
ted por ejemplo no fue tenido en cuenta
debido a un mejor ánimo esta es la casa
que he tenido desde 2012
la tomé después de que el jefe de
policía que vivía aquí se escapara en
2011 en ese momento no tenía casa mi
madre estaba conmigo mi padre estaba
enfermo así que vine aquí tomé la casa
esta es mi casa
miren como vivo aquí desde 2012 mira el
flujo de agua que tengo me quejé en la
municipalidad pedí agua le dije que era
un herido de la revolución
y que entregué mi cuerpo a este país se
negaron y dijeron que no tenía las
escrituras de la casa que era la casa
del jefe de policía
[Música]
chad y por su parte fue registrado entre
los heridos recibió una compensación
económica y médica de henna después de
los juicios nos ofrecieron puestos de
trabajo a cada uno de acuerdo con
nuestro nivel educativo también
obtuvimos una compensación económica de
los tribunales militares y el estado nos
dio una tarjeta de asistencia médica que
ya se venció y otra tarjeta para el
transporte gratuito
expiró en 2015 pero todavía la uso
pero xavi dice no haber obtenido
justicia la mayor parte de los policías
y funcionarios de seguridad fueron
condenados por negligencia en el manejo
de las protestas justicia no no hubo
justicia apoyo a la institución militar
y a sus tribunales que aún así no se
indemnizaron y presentaron algunas
evidencias en los juicios pero lo más
importante es que no revelaron toda la
verdad y no responsabilizaron realmente
a los culpables de sus actos
algunos juicios de la revolución fueron
reanudados en tribunales especializados
pero chad y considera que no hay
voluntad política para que el proceso de
reparación tenga éxito hoy la bala que
lo alcanzó sigue alojada en su pierna en
un lugar demasiado delicado para ser
operado un recuerdo doloroso al igual
que esos vídeos del levantamiento que ve
a menudo para no olvidar
ese fue el primer mártir que cayó
cómo se llama
para mí este vídeo evoca muchos
recuerdos y se está repitiendo a fin de
cuentas todos los años hay
manifestaciones siempre en enero se
calma la de cada uno
una década después de los
acontecimientos de 2011 muchos tunecinos
se preguntan que han ganado o perdido
con la revolución
[Música]
en sidi buzid la escultura de la carreta
del vendedor ambulante mohamed buazizi y
su retrato son los últimos vestigios de
la revuelta en la ciudad
se iba a dedicar un museo a la memoria
de este suceso sus puertas están
cerradas porque nunca acabó de ser
construido en los callejones del barrio
de agen ur
whitey y wafa recuerdan los primeros
momentos cuando salieron a protestar en
diciembre de 2010 es el café de la
revolución lo llamamos así después de
2011 porque todos los habitantes del
barrio se reunían aquí y también
teníamos una sala de huevos justo al
lado donde nos reuníamos para preparar
nuestras salidas y reuniones
tengo buenos recuerdos de la unidad del
pueblo durante las revoluciones todos se
apoyaban entre sí viejos y jóvenes
hombres y mujeres no es como ahora
cuando los partidos políticos nos dicen
y siempre nos preguntamos a qué
corriente pertenece el que protestó con
nosotros
los tunecinos están cansados de la
crisis económica y política que
atraviesa el país desde hace 10 años
wafa abás y también lo está fue golpeada
por la policía el 7 de enero de 2011
cuando salía a protestar la yihad side
la revolución comenzó porque nos
sentíamos marginados pero hasta el día
de hoy seguimos sufriendo esa
marginación en sidi buzid más del 85% de
los jóvenes del barrio que salir una
protesta en aquí no están registrados
con heridos en la revolución y no
presentaron sus expedientes para ser
ente analizados
no siempre hemos exigido proyectos para
la región esa ha sido siempre nuestra
reivindicación y eso es lo que dio
impulso a la revolución
el pez hasta ahora
aunque el centro de la ciudad de sidi
buzid ha sido restaurado desde 2011 la
gobernación con más de 400.000
habitantes se encuentra entre las
regiones del interior todavía marginadas
[Música]
las tasas de pobreza y desempleo siguen
siendo superiores a la media nacional
como en otras cunas de la revolución
los partidarios del régimen de ben alí
no dejan de utilizar este argumento
en un azul a pocos kilómetros de sidi
buzid nos encontramos con uno de los
representantes de la antigua orden
en 2011 messaoud fue uno de los
dirigentes locales de la agrupación
constitucional democrática el partido
presidencial que hacía y deshacía
carreras y otorgaba favores ilícitos
esta es mi escopeta me encanta esta
escopeta este fusil me salvó a mí a mi
mujer ya mis hijos de la muerte el 24 de
febrero de 2011 cuando fui atacado por
casi 1000 habitantes de la ciudad todos
los jóvenes llevaban latas de gas y
echaron la puerta abajo salir con este
fusil y disparé una vez al aire para
avisarles conseguí mantenerlos fuera
hasta que los militares oyeron el
alboroto e intervinieron si no hubiera
tenido este fusil habrían quemado la
casa
buscamos casa donde sea que nos ha
brindado
hoy este ex alcalde y senador de la
región sigue sintiéndose nostálgico esto
fue en las elecciones municipales es
cierto que el régimen no era
completamente democrático pero había un
poco de democracia de todas maneras hoy
en día sólo hay una cosa que se da por
sentada en túnez la libertad de
expresión que sobre todo nos permite
insultarnos
para mí eso no es democracia antes al
menos teníamos seguridad salud
y un poco de libertad
en la ciudad la sede donde messaoud
realizaba las reuniones del partido fue
saqueada durante la revolución y después
sellada como la mayoría de los símbolos
de la dictadura
algunos llaman revolución a eso que pasó
pero yo no yo lo llamaría un
levantamiento aunque empezó en mi región
habría sido una revolución si realmente
hubiera respondido a las expectativas
del pueblo pero no fácil de qué tipo de
revolución estamos hablando cuando vemos
el aumento del desempleo
ya jubilado messaoud sigue siendo
políticamente activo y apoya el rechazo
a la revolución que está de vuelta en la
escena política como este diputado del
partido de asturiano libre un partido
conservador de la línea de ben alí en
las encuestas su partido estar a la
cabeza en intención de voto para las
próximas elecciones legislativas
[Música]
esta ex abogada del partido del ex
dictador es también conocida por sus
posturas anti islámicas en el parlamento
no quiero hablar del 14 dinero porque no
me preocupo esa fecha y por lo tanto no
quiero hablar de ella uno de los pocos
políticos que reivindica un legado
revolucionario es caixa jet el nuevo
presidente elegido en 2019 con más del
72 por ciento de los votos lo defiende a
capa y espada
vine aquí hoy para decirles que
implementaremos sus peticiones
y aquellas de la revolución dentro del
marco de nuestra constitución
pero sin un verdadero apoyo partidista a
menudo aparece aislado es en este túnel
atrapado en la tentación de la
restauración y la continuidad de la
revolución donde el periodista más esti
ye'l así se apoderó de uno de los pocos
logros de 2011 la libertad de expresión
nos encontramos con él en náhuat un
medio de comunicación ciudadano donde
trabaja como freelance bajo el mandato
de ben ali mahdi fue encarcelado por su
trabajo en un periódico de la oposición
ahora puede escribir sobre cualquier
tema
la diferencia entre ayer y hoy es que
antes los empresarios eran afines al
antiguo régimen por lo que estaba
prohibido hablar de ellos o escribir
sobre ellos ahora podemos denunciar pero
también hablar de los políticos que los
protegen y por lo tanto presionarlos hoy
tenemos un poder judicial independiente
a pesar de todas las dificultades que
tuvimos después de la revolución todavía
vemos que los empresarios son condenados
e incluso los políticos van a la cárcel
incluso el proceso
sobre el terreno magdy es un periodista
comprometido fiel a los ideales de la
revolución como en enero en esta
manifestación de jóvenes contra el
gobierno y la represión policial
senegal
canales
para informar sobre el aire en las
manifestaciones y los problemas de
agresiones policiales el barrio
en el mismo tiempo el parlamento está
discutiendo un cambio de gabinete y
cuando hablo con estos jóvenes me dicen
que no les importa
durante este nuevo movimiento de
protesta la represión fue severa con
detenciones masivas
un duro recordatorio del legado de un
estado policial bajo el mandato de ben
alí que se esfuerza por reformar se
según este antiguo responsable del
aparato de seguridad quien nos recibe en
la plaza de la kasba de túnez uno de los
epicentros de la revolución en la
capital no creo que nadie pueda quitarle
al pueblo tunecino lo que se ha ganado
los que protestan por la noche este año
tenían ocho años durante la revolución
ahora tienen entre 15 y 20 años han
crecido con una nueva libertad nunca
volverán atrás no creo que la historia
pueda repetirse para él
diez años después estas reformas son
necesarias para responder a la ira en
los jóvenes
debemos lograr construir una policía
republicana que no tenga que trabajar
para los partidos políticos los
nombramientos en el ministerio del
interior no deben depender de intereses
partidistas en segundo lugar hay que
convencer a las fuerzas de seguridad de
que estén al servicio del pueblo y sólo
del pueblo pues si voy directamente
un estado de derecho aún en construcción
los tunecinos celebraron el décimo
aniversario de la revolución en un
confinamiento general en la avenida
burguiba donde hace diez años resonaban
los fuera reina un gran silencio
[Música]
llegamos al final de este episodio de
boleto de vuelta a sidi buzid os invito
a ingresar a nuestra página web france24
puntocom para ver este y otros
contenidos en español hasta pronto
[Música]